so we're told g of x is a transformation
for
of f of x the graph below shows f of x
is a solid blue line so this is a graph
of y is equal to f of x and g of x is a
dotted red line so that's the graph of y
is equal to g of x what is g of x in
terms of f of x and they gave us some
choices here and i encourage you pause
the video and see if you can figure this
out
well there's a couple of ways that you
could think about it one is if you just
eyeball it it looks like if you flipped
f of x over the x axis it looks a little
bit like g of x but g of x looks like a
version of that that's diminished a
little bit so for example if you were to
flip it perfectly over the x-axis you
would get something
you would get something that looks like
and i'm just going to sketch it
so if you just flipped perfectly over
the x-axis you would look you'd get
something that looks like this
and trying my best
to eyeball it it would look something
something like this if you perfectly
if you perfectly just flipped it over it
would look something like that i might
not get it perfectly right but that
would be this right over here so let me
be clear if this is y is equal to f of x
then this line right over here that i
just drew that would be y is equal to
negative f of x
so because whatever f of x would give
you just take the negative of it you're
flipping over the x axis and now g of x
looks like a diminished version of that
if i were to just eyeball it it looks
like it's roughly one-third of this so
my initial guess and we can verify this
a little bit is that this
that this right over here is one-third
the value of this so i would say it is
so g of x
is equal to
one-third of negative f of x or negative
one-third
of
f of x
and that is not one of the choices which
makes me extra cautious but let me just
let me just emphasize why i like this
choice because we said this is negative
f of x right there it looks like for any
x value what g of x is is one third of
that so instead of getting to four we're
getting to a little bit over one instead
of getting to
three right over here we're getting to
one instead of getting to one right over
here we are only getting to one-third so
it looks like it is one-third of this
line that i just hand drew which is
negative f of x would be one third of
negative f of x which would be negative
one third f of x
once again not a choice here but let's
actually look at some values so if we
said
let's see some values where it looks
like we're hitting integer integer
values
so
right at
so for example right at
this point
right over here
it looks like f of f of negative 7 is
equal to negative 1.
it looks like g of negative 7
is right so it looks like g of negative
7
is equal to positive 1 3
positive 1 3. if i'm just if i am just
eyeballing it so that seems consistent
with this because if f of if f of
negative 7 is negative 1 you take the
negative 1 3 times that and you get
positive one-third we can do that a
couple of other places if we look right
over
if we look
right over here
it looks like f of negative one
f of negative 1 is equal to negative 3
and it looks like g of 1
is negative 1 3 times that
negative 1 3 times that is that point
right over there negative 1 3 times
negative 3 is positive 1. so g
of
g is color in that red color
so we get
for that point right over there we get g
of negative 1 is equal to
positive 1. so once again this is
negative 1 3 times this right over here
so i feel pretty confident in my answer
g of x is equal to negative 1 3 times f
of x once again negative f of x we just
flipped over and then multiplying it by
the 1 3 diminishes that which we see
right over there so i feel pretty
confident
with my
none of the above